a future Hall of Famer and Chris Paul
his situation with the Phoenix Suns so
Chris Haynes reported this first sons
have notified Chris fall he will be
waved making him one of the top three
agents this off season the league
sources tell at NBA on TNT but Sean
sharania said this the sons and Chris
Paul are exploring multiple options
including a trade stretching his
contract and waving or resigning him in
free agency Phoenix expected to discuss
trades ahead of Paul's June 28th
contract date which we know is within
the next time that can't happen you
can't wave a guy stretch it outside you
can't do all three
one of them you can't I don't even think
you can collect the bargain agreement
allows you to do so we'll see but
clearly there's some there's some
confusion right and and a lot of times
right and we and we know Chris Sam's
they have impeccable sources around the
league and you know some are close to
the players some are close to the agents
and sometimes income conversation you
know things can get there are some
misunderstandings right and
all I know is this about Chris right
he's well respected not only is he well
respected he's well loved in the NBA
he's one of these guys that you know
over the last couple of years the
players have voted him
their president of the league so of the
NBA Players Association so when you talk
about his leadership it sounds questions
so whatever happens to Chris moving
forward whether it be with the sons
whether it be with another team whether
it be sources or whoever in this
uncertainty of situation I think we all
should just wish the best to him his
family because we all know as former
players how difficult these situations
and conversations can be and the
misunderstandings from these
conversations that can come out and play
in the public sector well Jamal this is
one of your former teammates right and
you and I have talked before about Chris
Paul's leadership yes what can he bring
to a team if he is playing for another
team next season leadership
competitiveness and just I think Love of
the Game is missing in the league around
the world and he has that to be at this
level to continue to play
no reason to play besides loving the
game I think that's contagious I think
more guys need to have that and I think
he has he's one of the few that I've
ever played with that love the game just
as much as I do well the one thing is
it's going to be a championship caliber
team and so he will be at peace if he
stays in Phoenix that's a piece to win a
championship he goes somewhere else
Chris Paul is not going on and
rebuilding situation no he's going to
win a championship somewhere or help a
team win a championship so that will be
very interesting because there are
multiple places that need Point Guard
Leadership
to get the ball to Biggs shooting guards
around the league and if it wasn't one
right now and it wasn't Phoenix he
wasn't going back to work
let's not let's not put him out of
Phoenix yet no no
if it was a piece
all the things you just said right those
are all the things that Phoenix needs
right but if it was in Phoenix where did
you see him going that he would fit his
game and where he's at his career
there's not a contender that he would
not fit it's just kind of like let's say
Philadelphia with Joel and B you move
hard into the two at times and now he
becomes a shooter like Maxi comes off
screens he could be a two he doesn't
have to have ball land there's a lot of
places like Chris Paul of course been
playing with you know LeBron you know
taking the ball out of broad hand so he
doesn't have to always be the
facilitator he can run the lanes you
know there's a lot of places and for
those wondering about the financial
aspect of it because for the Phoenix
Suns that's that would be their
motivation right they would get 10
million they could still spin under the
cap and then you could sign Chris Paul
for a lesser amount than what he's
making this year so people have to
understand that part of it yeah that's
why I say that there's a lot of there's
a lot of days there's a lot of room
there's a lot of conversation left in
this right because you know what you
just explained in terms of you know
waving and potentially coming back I
mean don't close the door on Phoenix
coming back him coming back and being a
part of the Phoenix Suns at least I
wasn't right now no I wouldn't either
absolutely nothing yeah and Chris Paul
showed great leadership even when he
wasn't playing in the postseason this
year we wish the best for Chris Paul in
his future